the deep blues of water anamorphic
lenses and contemplative MCU story
wakanda forever passionately honors the
legacy of Chadwick Boseman it's no
secret that black panther wakanda
forever is one of the most highly
anticipated MCU films so far the movie
serves both as a sequel to The Beloved
2018 Blockbuster Black Panther and as a
climactic finale to Marvel's phase 4 and
yet overshadowing all of the excitement
for wakanda forever is the notable
absence of actor Chadwick Boseman who
tragically passed away in 2020 following
an extended battle with colon cancer
from what we've seen thus far in the
trailers for wakanda forever it's clear
that Bozeman's Legacy will be a major
component of the film itself indeed it
appears that much of the film story will
be informed by the devastating loss of
Chadwick Boseman director Ryan coogler
confirmed earlier this year when he said
that the cast and crew put their love
for Chadwick into the film while
presenting a preview for the movie at
San Diego Comic-Con in fact Bozeman's
impact on wakanda forever is so great
that even the film's visual style was
influenced by his passing in a recent
interview with Entertainment Weekly
coogler mentioned how the visual style
of the movie is supposed to reflect the
immense loss felt after Bozeman's stats
he said I think this film has the fog of
loss over it anamorphic lenses warped
the image a little bit sometimes when
you go through profound loss it can warp
how you look at the world what we were
after was just making it feel tactile
even though it felt like a dream coogler
went on to explain that this is meant to
craft a film that is both intimate and
emotionally poignant while operating on
the scale of a massive superhero
Blockbuster in addition to the use of
warped lenses coogler addressed how the
shift in visual style includes an
emphasis on water and the color blue
something that should come as no
surprise since the film's primary
antagonist name or the Submariner is the
ruler of a vast undersea Kingdom what
contact will form of course since lost
and grief have so heavily informed the
storytelling and style of wakanda
forever it's no surprised that the
experience making it was melancholic for
those who knew and worked with Bozeman
on the previous movie while speaking to
collider Winston Duke who plays mbaku
explained that shooting the sequel was
strange without their old colleague on
the set however the experience helped
them come to terms with his death and
understand the grieving process Duke
said it was something that we dealt with
every day and something that we got to
understand every day that we're not the
only people grieving not only the people
who are in front of the camera are
grieving it's everybody elsewhere Lupita
Nyong'o who portrays Nakia recalled
having to meditate pray and reflect in
order to come to grips with the new
movie existing without her friend and
co-star it took the actress a while to
adjust to the idea of a sequel without
Bozeman but she understood that changes
were necessary she told the New York
Times I found myself having to radically
accept that this was going to be
different and that showing up with as
much openness as possible was key
wakanda forever was certainly an
emotional experience for everyone
involved but the movie promises to honor
the Legacy of both Bozeman and King
t'challa
[Music]